people of Gotham tis I mark here to
relieve you the little people of the
burden of wondering who is the best
Batman before I continue let's make sure
that we're all on the same page you are
correct local ruffian
there isn't one bat there's been many
bad people over the years Batman that
girl even bad boy stay cool but with the
recent news that Robert Pattinson will
be filling out the cape and cowl we
decided it was high time to declare a
greatest Batman of them all your
contestants are Adam West Michael Keaton
Val Kilmer George Clooney Kevin Conroy
Christian Bale Ben Affleck and Will
Arnett here's how we'll determine a
winner
round 1 box office round 2 tomato meter
round 3 most iconic and then we'll do a
wild card round the crowd is at a fever
pitch the villains are watching from
Arkham Asylum and the Batman they're at
home washing their tights let's get it
on this is going to be an easy win for
one of two possible contenders so before
we named those billionaire Playboy's
let's take a gander at some honorable
mentions Ben Affleck step right up
you never got a chance to shine in your
very own Batman flick apples which I do
not like however he got to play bats in
both Batman V Superman dawn of justice
and injustice league both flicks
combined to gross 593 million dollars
domestically and 1.6 billion dollars
worldwide not a bad effort at all
especially when you consider that Val
Kilmer and George Clooney's combined
outings grossed 615 million here in the
states and 1.19 seven billion across the
globe
never leave the cave without it
unfortunately this is a biased category
for tv-friendly Batman Adam West and
Kevin Conroy their bread was mainly
buttered respectively on Batman two TV
series and Batman the Animated Series
Adam West did get a feature film but it
was just a different time and I don't
have the box office numbers for the 1966
flick was Lincoln on the penny back then
and while Kevin Conroy is Batman has had
two feature films they still do the bulk
of their damage on VHS DVD blu-ray and
streaming sales in theaters his Batman
flicks have done a combined sixteen
million dollars internationally it's a
lot of money to me but not to Batman
interior animated box-office news Will
Arnett's Lego Batman did a hundred and
seventy nine million dollars in the US
of A and three hundred and twelve
million dollars over all of earth if you
add in his appearances from the tool
dull Lego movies it brings us worldwide
total haul to an even 1 billion dollars
and then there were two this is Keaton
vs. Bale all the way Bale did a full
trilogy and Keaton although he was
reportedly offered a full dumptruck of
$100 bills to come back for a third time
only did Batman 1989 and its sequel the
accurately titled Batman Returns bails
The Dark Knight is the highest-grossing
flick in the caped crusaders history
getting six hundred ninety eight million
dollars domestically and 1.3 billion
dollars worldwide in second place is
Batman 1989 with five hundred and ninety
million dollars here in the States and
nine hundred and sixty six million
internationally all told bails three
movies did three point nine four five
billion dollars in total earth bucks
while Keaton's two talkies add up to one
point five six billion dollars so why
does Keaton win this round well quite
simply if it weren't for him and his
Batman we wouldn't have any of these
other bad folk around seriously both his
films were massive hits in way less
theaters than the Dark Knight trilogy
and him saying no to a third Batman film
open the door for our modern world of
quick superhero reinvention Val got his
chance then George and George's movie
was so bad it was actually good why her
all the gorgeous ones homicidal maniacs
is it me in that we got to do a total
reboot with a guy named Christopher
Nolan at the helm which gave us
Christian Bale I'm so good at explaining
stuff I should have been a teacher
Keaton's competitive per movie average
combined with the fact that it was in
less theaters with less show times plus
the fact that he got there first it all
adds up to give him the round one win
well done Mikey Comfort let's go shall
we
[Applause]
home like the criminals of Gotham City
moviegoers tend to get excited when
Batman comes around but what about the
critics if Christopher Nolan's trilogy
is to be considered the tomato meter
seems to favor the bat Christian Bale's
3 flicks have a super fresh average of
88% that's got to be the top of the
mountain right actually Will Arnett's
one stand alone bat flick the Lego
Batman movie is sitting at 90% plus the
original lego movie is at 96% relax
everybody I'm here but if we're going by
single bat centric movie accomplishments
Christian Bale wins out again his The
Dark Knight is the king at 94% Ben
Affleck's a cool Batman for sure but his
veggies have turned as his two flicks
average of rotten 34% he's still in good
company as Val Kilmer's Batman Forever
is at 39% and maybe we can just all
agree to not even mention Batman and
Robin during this segment Michael
Keaton's two flicks averaged 76% and for
funsies guess which one is higher it's
Batman Returns that's at 79% while the
1989 reintroduction of Batman is at 74%
so bails only real competition here is
with og Adam West and Kevin Conroy Adam
West's one Batman film is at 78% but if
you factor in the TV series he leaves
all the way up to 85.5% holy be average
Batman look hail storm Kevin Conroy
films have a fresh average of 62%
but when you include the animated shows
he's
he jumps up to 80% good efforts all
around and for my money
Justice League isn't as bad as everyone
says you know what I'm not dying on this
hill again when your worst outing is
Batman is that 84% fresh and the tomato
meter that means two things are true
your name is Christian Bale and you've
just won round two
well done it's not who I am underneath
but what I do that defines me
[Music]
as an icon myself I know being iconic is
all about making memorable moments now a
memorable moment isn't always
necessarily a good thing
take val kilmer solid Batman good
brooding Bruce Wayne but his most
memorable moment telling Alfred he'll
get drive-thru
I'll get drive-thru come on Bruce we're
already watching your movie we're going
to Mickey D's after don't hit us over
the head with it
it's gonna go in some way for Michael
Keaton his most iconic moment is a tie
between a good one and a crazy one in
the line that definitively announced to
the world that there's a new superhero
movie in town he grabs a Gotham Street
tough and simply says I'm Batman
that's how you scare a criminal also
seen in Batman 1989 is Michael Keaton
reverting to his Beetlejuice days when
he says to the Joker what a great moment
for the whole family
bring the kids hell we got plenty of
snakes and lizards for him to play with
some Batman had their best and worst
moment at the same time I got two words
for you sharks prey when a shark is
gnawing on Batman's leg and he's
struggling to get his handy shark
repellent from his utility belt it's not
only the stupidest thing ever it's also
a perfect summation of the Campina that
the original Batman series was going for
Christopher Nolan's trilogy was going
for something darker as evidenced by one
of Bale's classic moments towards the
end of the Dark Knight rajah fails at
his most iconic when he's straining his
voice so hard as the Caped Crusader that
it borders on insanity a mirage okay The
Joker interrogation scene and his escape
from Ra's al Ghul's home for wayward
boys is pretty sweet too
the father to see yourself hello fella
speaking of dark how about Kevin Conroy
is Batman and broody to the max and he's
got some killer lines like in the mask
of the phantasm or my personal favorite
from the animated series Knight
[Music]
whoo you open with that it's an instant
swipe right ladies am I wrong here
rounding out the bad folk George Clooney
really only has dull moments Will Arnett
has some genuinely funny stuff and is a
great study of the Batman pathos but the
only real contender here is Ben Affleck
Ben has a great moment early on at
Batman V Superman when he's running
towards danger as everyone else is
fleeing dude really fills out a Men's
Wearhouse vest nicely however by the end
of that flick we're all ready for the
big climax and then what happens Martha
that's what stops you dude you're
killing an alien you got him on the
ropes your ma could show up Brucie stop
hurting the poor thing and you'd still
finish him off come on man don't believe
everything you hear
it's a brawl between Christian Bale and
Michael Keaton for this round and you
know what it's actually Kevin Conroy
that's your winner right here
maybe he wasn't on as many magazine
covers when his animated movies came out
but if we're talking about iconic
moments there's one in practically every
episode of Batman the Animated Series
and every movie he's in is jam-packed
with Bruce bats conflict with his films
and the show he had the most opportunity
the most amount of canvas with which to
paint and he got to go against the best
Joker ever Mark Hamill Don Roy wins
round three
[Music]
and now it's time for the wildcard round
the greatest social impact now this one
is gonna be Michael Keaton versus
Christian Bale Kevin Conroy is great wes
is a legend the others had a nice time
[ __ ] what if we're looking at who
influenced the landscape with their
greatest detective more it comes down to
these two hunks Michael Keaton gets some
points for what went down even before he
started shooting
once it was announced that mr. mom was
gonna be Batman people lost their minds
it was the first time in the modern era
that a true [ __ ] was flipped over a
comic book movie casting 50,000 fans
sent in protest letters hoping to
convince Tim Burton to fire Johnny
dangerously and this was before the
Internet you actually had to like write
a letter and put a stamp on it and send
it somewhere the fans really hated this
idea initially but then from opening
night on people saw what a brilliant
actor can do with this role of duality
and Keaton cemented himself as a
versatile a list movie star I want you
to tell all your friends about Batman
1989 as a film was a cultural landmark
all summer long it was bat mania I know
because I lived it did you know there
was a run on black cotton t-shirts
because so many people were buying them
up to make contraband Batman shirts I
probably owned one or nine it ruled the
entire year and I also remember in the
summer of 1992 a bunch of parents
freaking out because the penguin bit a
guy's nose and blood goes gushing
everywhere
so apparently parents were cool with
Batman murdering a gaggle of killer
clowns twenty minutes ago but a little
plasma was over-the-line ah parenting
hope it never happens to me
Christian Bale steps into a very
different world than Michael Keaton in
2005 audiences were primed and ready for
a darker grittier type of hero and who
better to give that to them than
American Psycho Patrick Bateman led a
double life so does Bruce Wayne Batman
Begins aside from being my personal
favorite comic book film ever also
helped usher in a new dawn for the
superhero movie it was part of a tidal
wave that were still surfing today but
it wasn't until the dark
night that the social impact was truly
felt why so serious The Dark Knight
showed movie critics what fans had hoped
for all along these kind of movies could
be taken just as seriously as cinema as
any other flick it taught us that the
term superhero movie wasn't necessarily
a hindrance to award chances in fact
because the source material was so
fantastical these types of roles would
allow serious actors to show off their
chops in new inventive ways so how does
one choose between these two when both
were part of nothing less than an entire
paradigm shift well because we're
looking at Batman specifically and while
Christian Bale was a huge part of the
Dark Knight trilogy 'he's greatness the
lion sheriff prays for these films
standing head and shoulders above
previous Batman efforts was thanks to
Christopher Nolan and it was Heath
Ledger's Joker that led the way for
films like this to be critically
acclaimed so while Michael Keaton
certainly had help from the likes of Tim
Burton Jack Nicholson and Michelle
Pfeiffer it was his genius portrayal of
a tortured soul that redefined what an
audience would expect from a superhero
Michael Keaton is a great Bruce Wayne
and awesome crime fighter in short the
best Batman in history he wins this
round and he wins the match yep that
Robert Pattinson has some big boots to
fill be it from any of the previous bad
folk that had to figure out how to pee
while wearing that cumbersome suit just
for some fun Marc Hoffmeyer the Alfred
to my Robin compiled a bunch of lists
ranking the best Batman from a slew of
different polls his results showed that
it's actually Christian Bale who takes
the mantle as the bat goat and a Kevin
Conroy is a silver medalist Keaton was a
close third but it just proves what but
no it does not prove that I'm a [ __ ]
it proves that our own opinions matter
the most so now it's your turn dear
viewer comment below with a person who
you think is the best Batman of all time
is it Michael Keaton is it Kevin Conroy
Nicolas Cage is Big Daddy who you got
and defend your answer head while you're
at it do you think Robert Pattinson has
the chops to add another exciting
chapter in the Batman legacy remember
Pattinson
you are my number one the guy alright
that's all for me today I'm taking off
and I'm a little hungry but it's ok I'll
get drive-thru
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]